welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Sam Raimi's spider-man 3 blew up
this trilogy with more more villains or
a thanks and more meaningful moments I'm
gonna put some dirt in your eyes look a
little Kaplan junior gonna cry
you'll get your rent when you fix this
damn door no actually that last one is
more important than you think how all of
the moments in this movie deserve
re-examination because despite insane
studio pressure Raimi still managed to
build this film with tons of fascinating
overlooked visual details we here at new
rock stars are on month four of weekly
retro free watches and back in June new
kind folks voted the Raimi trilogy as
the successor to spider-man three opens
with another Webb framed recap montage
but even before the Venom symbiote
infects everything
Peter's webbing is already cast in
shadow definitely compared to its
predecessor reflecting how the darkness
that overtakes Peter in this film is
already inside him with his ego his lack
of empathy and his vengeance our first
shot of spider-man is actually resampled
footage from the final swing sequence of
spider-man 2 but with all those warm
color tones dulled Peter watches this on
a screen from the street and we're
reminded of those final moments from the
previous film and it's secretly dark
undertone the tiger go and getting them
oblivious to MJ's concern a blindness
that poisons him in this film Peter is
blinded by loving headlines including
one written by Ray Frank homage to
spider-man comic anchor Frank Sequoia
who went under the name Frank ray and
Peter's blinded by the blondie in dr.
Connors class Gwen Stacy which is
reflected by the literal blinding
distraction of his bullies but you can
actually see a quick flash of earlier
spitballs and flashes and high school
spit balls and flashes in college Ivy
League science class okay but first do
you want to be the hero of your own
fantasy of course you do and that's why
you should play raids shadow legends it
is a game where dark fantasy meets
realism and where a lizard man meets a
frozen banshee guess what they don't get
along raid is free to download and play
and available on both mobile and desktop
I like to play in the dungeon battles
where you can get a spot of your
champions and you get to take on a boss
and his goons for a great reward you can
upgrade your champions and outfit them
with cool artifacts and make them
stronger you can join the clan and fight
the clan boss and you can jump to the
arena to fight against other raid
players and now the brand new tag-team
arena is live in game hag arena is the
next level of competition player versus
player battles a series of three four
versus four battles exactly the big
battle an Avengers endgame but it's as
close you can get with Dark Elves and
skinwalkers Ansah this brand new the
developers will be giving out some
special rewards soon - whoever manages
to finish high up in the rankings you
can find me in the game under the
username new rock 2020 so what are you
waiting for go to the live video
description click on the special links
and if you're a new player you will get
50,000 sober 50 gems 1 energy refill 1
clay and boskie 5 mystery shards one day
xp booster and one free epic champion
that champion is Shaymin and she's
really great for kicking butt in the
early stage of the game all this
treasure will be waiting for you here be
quick because the rewards will be
available only for the next 30 days good
luck and I'll see you there MJ sings
irving berlin's they say it's wonderful
and peters too dumb sing-along the words
that he doesn't realize the lyrics are
actually lamenting coming from someone
idealized in the concept of love without
having experienced the real thing
themselves and in his literal blind spot
is the John Wilkes Booth in the Opera
box
serios born pale and clammy showing that
he is definitely following his father's
footsteps with these physical
transformations after birth Peter tells
MJ the applause was louder than she
thought its acoustics it's all about
diffusion it keeps the sound waves from
grouping you see when the sound waves
they propagate then it's like an and
there are such a nerd mmm Peter's
knowledge of the physics of sonic
frequencies sets him up figuring out
Venom's weakness in the final act
grouping sound waves to destabilize the
Scindia aries goblin cave includes a
silver in gold goblin mask a nod to the
Hobgoblin identity from the comics
though technically Harry Osborn in this
movie is listed as new goblin he
snowboards okay Peter and MJ stargaze
with one of these shooting starts
containing the symbiotes this final
perfect night broken with a cursed wish
because literally in the next 24 hours
Harry will attack Peter MJ will get by
fermer show in Eddie Bracknell
threatened Peters career this toxic
symbiote is designed to have a more
pliable stickier doughy texture than the
more liquidy goos of the comics
it has animalistic movement that grasps
and latches on to its prey and that
grasp is reflected in the black suit
spider logo with its legs bent inward
like claws
now the word venom is never actually
spoken in this film but the venom V logo
does make a photo cameo and the way that
it first makes contact with Peter
latching onto his plate forming a V
shape Flint Marcos Sandman wears his
iconic green and brown outfits got a
sick kid penny Marco all this from the
comics and he says not a bad person
just had bad luck later after Peter
snaps at his landlord about his damn
door
mr. dickham [ __ ] says he is good boy it
must be some kind of parallelism they're
both Flint and Peter are in a way
responsible for Ben Parker's death and
that parallelism here is designed to
teach Peter forgiveness in this film
Peters moped helmet still has the torn
off Joe's pizza sticker and when they
fight Harry tears a chunk out of the
building wall when it flips on the other
side is like the interior wallpaper all
of it mostly attacked cleanly stuck to
the brick and plaster there Peter ends
up using Harry's own drone against him
slingshotting it back so that Harry
misses the tripwire
[Applause]
okay come now Harry's Anita in this
movie made him forget this particular
move that's why later he's caught off
guard when Peter uses it on him again
happy Harry says this about Peter and MJ
can manage for them which he does later
now MJ is upset about her bad reviews
but Peter keeps making this about him
try and understand how I feel I look at
these words it's like my father uncle
Peter can't understand because back in
the first movie he blocked out MJ's
father yelling at her were you listening
to that no well I heard what I was just
taking out the trash I guess you can
always hear us everybody shouts and
Peter still kind of has that boyish
immaturity he minimizes her real pain
with stupid get back on that horse pep
talks no empathy just assuming the
headlines will swing back up for her as
they did for him like Sandman and venom
his friend Harry Peters conflict with MJ
is an amorphous target that you can't
really Webb together with a simple fix
some wounds just go too deep this movie
is all about detox the long ugly process
of true healing and how it usually it
gets worse before it gets better
also note how this scene begins it's
stuck again
Peter's broken damn door is a toxic
wound a metaphor that Fester's and
Fester's until you'll get your rent when
you fix this and then only later when he
completely breaks that handle letting
Aunt May in does he open himself up to
change in the wound begins to heal Peter
saves Gwen from an evil construction
crane where we meet her father captain
Stacy and Eddie Brock Edward Brock jr. I
worry the Daily Bugle
and I'm dating your daughter who love
this because both are lies he doesn't
yet work at the bugle as a full-time
employee he's a freelancer was even
mentioned in the first movie problem is
we don't have a decent picture Eddie's
been on it for weeks we could barely get
a glimpse of him
and he and Gwen are not dating about
that amazing amazing night that we've
had we've had it coffee Eddie if you
think about it that night ended with
Gwen and not staying the night due to a
gig the next morning I don't know I just
saw her last night she said she had a
modeling gig and there's the bugle
offices frame and past front pages in
previous movies spider-man Green Goblin
terrorized bugle from the attack in the
first film Doc Ock still at large which
we solve in piecing together in the
second movie as well as spider-man no
more and Stan Lee makes one of his
all-time best cameos you know I guess
one person can make a difference
enough said Peter takes Harry home catch
you little homecoming present mmm I use
basketball cool
we actually saw this in their shared
apartment in the first movie and you'll
notice Harry now wears his big jacket a
red sweater just like we saw him the
very first time on that field trip
getting all these reminders of all times
these two best friends but area also
hung up a portrait of his father the
portrait he's sitting in that same chair
that's right there so you know Harry
would sit there beneath Daddy looking at
the mirror at both of them saying thank
you baby now there was that woman in
black who hung there in that same frame
in the first film
it was either Harry's mother or his
grandmother which led to Norman's black
dress pink and why you gave him J a
looky-loo after Harry made her wear
black at Thanksgiving it's a weird
family
Peter's cocky dancing actually starts
early in this movie actually there's
this drummer who reached out to me on
Twitter
Chris Romero who said that the marching
band was his actual high school band
from Port Chester New York and you can
hear them playing these 60s animated
spider-man theme yeah Peter also snuck
in another shows I am call back to his
DC superhero reference in the first film
damn Peter finds MJ hey beautiful
one more notice our MJ was happy for a
second to be complimented a stranger who
actually likes her but then I realized
it was just her boyfriend who always has
to say that and that's why Peter second
photo is of her brief disappointment
instead he's left with just an InFocus
photo of a banner calling him mighty and
he it's a humiliating this girlfriend by
giving when he and MJ's upside down kiss
notice how he gives a thumbs up but he
inverts it to thumbs up from our
perspective although for him this is the
thumbs down which is accurate because
this is a big mistake Peter now one of
the armored truck guard is actually a
cameo by producer grant Curtis his name
actually also appeared on Norman's
newspaper in the first film spider-man
punches through Sandman's midsection
inspired by comics imagery they actually
pulled off this effect with martial arts
expert and amputee Baxter humbiy and
when Peter dumps the Santa of his boots
later I love how you can see stirrups on
his pant legs to keep them from riding
up clever Bruce Campbell returns as a
maitre d at the restaurant after playing
the wrestling announcer and snooty I
sure in the previous films
set him up as the failed actor Quinton
BEC Mysterio in the prologue of the
fourth film but it never happened Peter
tells him to play MJ song from the show
she was just fired from which again was
a much sadder song that he doesn't
really get the lyrics of and even though
he doesn't know she was fired she would
have had to sing the song like eight
times a week and then hundreds of times
before that at rehearsals it's just a
terrible choice in every way and then
he's so smug as he rehearses his
reactions to this proposal how'd that
get in there
well later turn this from sweet to
acidic after his dark turn
cry Peter Norman Osborn's his own
proposal oh and when he fishes out the
ring from the champagne you can actually
see the original spider bite scar on his
hand the gift and the curse that doomed
his personal relationships that curse
rots as his vengeance turns on Flint
Marko his memories trigger him with
flashes and camera shutter sound effects
photographers mind snapping photos of
the past until they overexposed beyond
recognition into blinding rage and his
monochromatic memories lead to a black
and white suit devoid of color his world
upside-down Peter gets its revenge on
Marko he grinds the guy's head into the
train and if you go through this frame
by frame you can actually see how the
VFX artists animated Marco's teeth
flying out of his jaw yeah Peter's
delivering the pain equivalent of
pulling teeth Peter goes emo and yeah
let's go for the turkey here you'll get
your rent when you fix this damn door on
MJ's phone or the names Sherlock er get
singer and gelfman they're all people
who worked in the prop Department on
this film nice snuff their names in the
phone there Randazzo is also someone who
worked payroll on the movie though there
is some wordplay here because Juliet
gelfman Randazzo was also the name of an
actress known for her work in the film
deconstructing Harry which the subplot
does for Harry Osborn here but as Peter
is retriggered with his vengeance memory
so is Harry first we attack his harm a
callback to Norman's demon voice telling
him that in the first film first
attack his heart Harry forces MJ to dump
Peter and then he taunts Peter she was
fired and she told you she didn't tell
me no this is a reversal from the first
film
when MJ worked as a waitress and told
Peter don't tell Harry who was her
boyfriend then but now it's a game of
don't tell Peter and then this Jim how's
the pie and then he magically disappears
behind the truck guy behind them is like
the hell why are you staying behind that
wall dude you know Frank is like I'm
getting my friends so good it's so good
sam raimi reveals Peter in Harry's
window with a similar camera move that
he did for Doc Ock in the previous film
and then they fight protected you in
high school now I'm gonna kick your
little ass Peters reax is actually
hilariously sincere because back when
Peter did get jumped in high school
Harry stayed on the sidelines
which one the beater taunts look a
little Kaplan junior gonna cry and then
he flings the grenade back at Harry
torching Harry's face the same way
Norman did to Peter in the final act of
the first film and he can actually see
Harry's body going flying that's just
Peter walks away
youch Peter sees Eddie's doctored photo
on the bugle front page I'm gonna put
some dirt in your eye comedian Dean
Edwards cameos there and on the lower
banner on that newspaper reads minor
wakes felt throughout Subway referring
to Peters fight with Marco on the trains
but if you think about this is the first
time Peter was written up bored
something bad he actually did of course
Jameson had to retract the doctored
photo he didn't have to print a full
retraction exonerating spider-man sees
everything about in spite of my would at
least be guilty of like aggravated
assault
Peter crashes the beagles champagne
toast for a new staff photographer I
don't think they do that but okay you
trashed Rock notice on Eddie's desk is
an already framed photo of Gwen a girl
who made it clear they were not dating
and then Peter humiliates Eddie you want
forgiveness good religion doing so Peter
creates his own demon sending Eddie to
the church where Eddie will get the
venom dripped on him behind dr. Connors
is a reptilian skeleton a nod to his
planned future as the lizard in the
fourth film that yeah never happened and
Peter's snatch its back that bugle job
and as he sits the Jameson's desk I love
the reaction of Benny Brandt through the
window there yes please a nerdy Brook
photographer and then Peters black suit
and is dancing well it's a it's enough
to feed an army on tumblr right but
notice those clearance signs on the
store yeah this is meant to be pathetic
because Peters broke he could only
afford new clothes that were on sale
that's the joke here Rainey wants us to
cringe at this because this is what a
nerd like Peter thinks is cool Randy's
not trying to be cool here he knows how
to make characters look cool when he
wants to but really he's an expert in
cringe body horror that is the gross
transformation we're looking at here the
jazz club is the horror movie equivalent
of the cursed a-hole bleeding out on
everyone and it's why rainy includes his
horror partner in crime evil ed -
co-writer Scott Spiegel in this moment
they're both a reveling in this horror
that's why it ends with the most
horrific violent
in any of these movies you just hit MJ
yeah rock bottom folks he's as bad as
this movie's 12 villains and that
prompts his first real step toward detox
using the Bell frequency to remove the
symbiotes which then binds to another
desperate soul who's also at rock-bottom
Eddie Brock
Peter cleanses himself with a shower and
he's back to square one gazing up at MJ
through a window just like he did from
his bedroom in the first movie Eddie
Brock venom suspends MJ's taxi in a web
with the message
spider-man stop us if you can written in
the same font from these sensational
spider-man comics this construction site
setting and composer Christopher young
Sam and music was inspired by an episode
of the animated spider-man and his
amazing friends young cameoed in this
movie as MJ's musical composer Sam
Raimi's sons Lauren and Henry cameo and
his daughter Emma cameos as a girl who
sells dreams in the camera that's you
Harry
saves Peter by taking these same blow
that killed his father you know the one
oh and Peter uses its sound waves to
destabilize the symbiote off Eddie but
Eddie it's too far gone unlike being bad
it makes me happy the Eddie is the boil
to Peter on this detox journey to
addicted to the toxin to let go of it
and at that last second you can see
Eddie skeleton vaporized and after
seeing his dark foils grisly end Peter
turns to a boil with more mixed morals
like him Flint Marko who reveals bends
shooting was an accident and Peter
realizes that they're both equally
guilty of this I've done terrible things
too so when Peter says I forgive you
he's really taking Aunt May's advice and
he's forgiving himself the trilogy comes
full circle with the ending of the first
movie and Osborn funeral in flash flops
and Joe Manganiello returns from the
first movie here though while the
previous two movies ended with
triumphant sunset swings this movie ends
on a quieter note MJ forgiving Peter in
Peters face is actually a mix of relief
and pain he doesn't get the kiss here he
knows he's lucky to get this much small
steps that is how we grow look I know
it's fun to dunk on this movie it
definitely isn't perfect Sam Raimi
himself later said it was awful I think
that's a pretty respectable thing for a
great filmmaker to say personally I've
always believed that it's the harder and
more rewarding path to investigate and
celebrate the artistry and Sam Raimi did
so many great things in this movie that
I am stoked he's getting a second chance
at Marvel with Doctor Strange to join
our future weekly watch the lungs on
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars movie I
should do next follow me on instagram at
EA vas followed me rock stars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching and hey I
said something you disagreed with in
this video try not to comment down below
with
[Applause]
[Music]